che bello che siamo simili tu mi hai
copiato però no è lei che ha copiato me
tu mi stai leccando la suola delle
scarpe a quanto vedo io però qui siamo
tutti uguali tranne cappello e io gli
occhiali e per un incredibile facciale
ed ipertesi anche parti autore e cio
ragione si io ci credo
dove andiamo mi dica lei faccia lei
tutto lei ad e fare dai talk ha
sottoscritto un po a carlos a veneto
pistola l'oua già c'è qualcuno qua e
sono io sono io se uno dietro spari
signor gatto ma cosa fa ma guardi rileva
rumore rumore non è un po no no non può
farmi credito laws mitragliato e ho
visto massmedia creato più per terra
vabbè ma alla fine ha capito lei se
sparando il colpo va esattamente dove si
spaccano riprenderanno al caso e alla
simpatia e il personaggio a chi lo sta
manovra king non trovo neanche mezza no
l'ho vista io l'ho vista io l'ho vista
il gas
no no non si permetta lo sa per motore
pietro nell'animazione venga qui guardi
a perfetto proprio questo tutto non c'è
gente non mi piace questa cosa voglio
vorrei voglio guadagnarmi la mia
vittoria quindi andiamo a parlare forum
eccolo vada ma ad argomento avanti a me
salito su c'è il davanti e dove sono io
deve finire mi dia un obiettivo però
perché sennò faccio io faccio i dati
posso vedermi in terza persona
questa cosa bellissima ha lì sotto c'è
qualcosa colpi i brutti poi li prende
vederci no no si fermi clicca qui
ok andiamo ma lei non ha gli occhi sulla
faccia ci sono dei problemi ma perché ha
gli occhi sopra la testa perché lei ha
davanti a me sulla bicicletta io devo
vedere su star non ha non faccio
obiezioni ha ragione però ancora più
bizzarra di noi e la nostra ombra tra
l'altro però c'è un'altra bicicletta
andiamo con due con una come vuole
possiamo fare la gara va bene
23 si parte
ricevo la salita non vale allora le ho
cercato di farlo se mandare in quanto
mamma mia che brutta cosa ho fatto
ma lei mi ha scelto la strada più breve
maledizione quanto è difficile questa
che arrivò 30 qua a tutta birra e
maledizione persona e non vale fa queste
fallo è che sarà arbitro dove lei lo ha
tagliato la strada davvero io venga
venga venga venga veloce prego più mutui
ap secondo me ci uccidono un tempo di
uscire siamo già morti e niente è la
tirata
no no no spari spari lo sto prendendo da
dietro forse loro due occhio resista
signor gatto resistano colei che arrivo
arrivo a sparente e niente io sono
fiduciosi siamo guardi lo trovate
assistito prima o al priamar mai
successo funziona molto bene il
matchmaking questo gioco perché ci mette
tutti distanti di solito però la gente
simpatica si parla devo prova da ma non
ne va di vadi veloci niente vengo via
arrivo non memoria e niente appena detto
e io provo a sparare alla gente la gente
non muore lo psico lo uccida feci bravos
il ragazzo accidente questo the sign
organi tokyo e ma come facciamo noi e il
milan ha deciso qualche arrivato
sandokan
niente al tipo messicano non sembrava
tanto contento va bene e mi sta seguendo
la regola venga aver assolutamente che
venga venga lei che questo cambi poco
chiaro però se del bene del bello e
vecchio aia l'ho tirato una padella
dispari dispari che lo scopo della ndaw
bobba del vergine si chiamava ma non può
morire se a terra cosa sparano la
conosce da leasing accuse non per terra
ferito non può morire
lei non sa le cose c'è un'altra persona
venga venga ogni volta che mi allontano
è possibile
l'ho ucciso è in gaven ga è un trattore
cosa ha avviato qua manigoldi se bravo
bravo signor gatto occhio però ci va
preso campo dal club l'ho fatto
malissimo ma anche lui venga qui venga
qui che cherchi che non posso darle
supporto ho preso tantissimo agli occhi
dolore lui l'ho colpito forte lohan che
non lo so se lui
guai a chiamarle via che male ancora
l'hack è male forte con la cia un
cecchino mi sto abbastanza potente venga
giù venga giù non sono riuscito
ucciderne neanche uno però va bene a me
assegnato che uno l'ho ucciso l'altro e
devo farlo fuori con le fregole lecce e
non ho più alto al pdl marzo di lei a
riduzione sono incastrato nella finestra
e non lo vedo è qui che saltella eccolo
possono i due no vabbè quanto tempo per
restare per si stia fermo alla maglia
che spaventa mi sono veramente spavento
ceca vado via signor gatto stia bene
sono morto in gattile che kakà mi sono
veramente cagato sotto arrivo e non è
morto e vabbè durerò poco da 11 a live
che peccato eravamo arrivati vicini sul
monza era vinta cavoli vabbè dai mi
faccio provare tanto siamo alla fine
periodo di benessere riuscire a fare
metto il per 4 sulla pistola e cicale
passo credo io con lei
e vabbè è stato bello abbiamo provato
facciamo ancora una che dice qui apposta
cos'è cosa ho trovato cos'è un taser
non so quanto sia forte un tesero
termici sono in questo giorno cosa vedo
qua ma fra loro non vorrei sbilanciarmi
abbandonare mancherò di aver ritrovato
la roma più forte del gioco vengono può
essere avrei sbilanciarmi come dice
secondo me abbiamo vinto lo provi la
prego ho bisogno di sapere non muoia
nomi sparito e venere pavimento nel
mezzo al venga qui e ci uno morto a
terra ha imprecato inter 18 l'attenzione
aspettare aspettiamo di qualche si
provavano a valutare eccolo spari gli
spari signor gatto
mamma mia che schifo lo ha ucciso con
mamma mia
chiamava mamma mia io non so se il
tesale fortissimo ho avuto solo sfiga ci
ha avuto solo culo la renda legati a
questa volta è ma
non la prendevo mi sono messo troppo
bene di armi non posso fare questi
cambiamenti mamma quante armi ci sono
sento un veicolo un elicottero ma se ci
sono non è il veicolo e il limite della
mappa dovevo andare via forare il sedile
miseria ma c'è ancora uno sulla bici qui
venga laing ago
mi sto facendo mi ha ucciso venga uno
sulla bici venga qua spari spari signor
gaspari non si faccia uscire ma no
signor gaber a da solo quello era da
solo poi farne un'altra
l'ultima ball vada vada ha lavorato così
in altro che ho superato la freccia
ci chiediamo giustizia ed eroina che
siamo e mi è piaciuta molto a quello sul
tetto sul lodo mi sta veramente cadere
sopra per civil è ribaltato malissimo
ok abbiamo armi giuste ott rotoli un
calibro 50 bene prima e l'ottica di
questo calibro 50 non è proprio il
massimo perché vicino che preteso in
volta ma fa mi ha fatto veramente paura
come si permette di indossare un gilet
raggiungendo da lei vuole già mettere la
colonna sonora si faccia brino di
livello c è chiarissimo guardi lei fa
una paura abbiamo già vinto aiap ma è
pazzo diminuisce delle qualità di
intelligenza quello forse livello delle
coreografie vado vado è bellissimo
trasportarla perché non hai idea di
quanto sia confortevole vedere eccolo lì
si giri si giri verso di me mi faccia
vedere meraviglioso
eccoli a sud pieno lo uccido ombra e
sono forte qua c'è ancora un altro qua
ho colpito ma non l'ha ucciso spari
spari signor gallo poco rumore rumore
dato è morto è morto
dunque siamo nella zona sicura strano e
11 alive questa me la sento ma l'aver
già va detto da quando dico queste cose
funziona sempre che vinciamo poi con un
9 halilhodzic reso signor gatto non
faccia cagate e io sia stia seduto e
buono
io ogni tanto mi giro verso di lei e
capisco che sono in finale con lei un po
mi deprimo però in realtà è una cosa
livello 5 pali quindi alla fine
preferiva la banana 9 del cetriolo baino
cetriolo giusto guardi come mi mimetizza
nel verde
mamma mia non si vede proprio lei però
lo rosa ora e attenzione dietro la
roccia giu lei ha preso l'albero
comprimario ottimo il cav h bruttissima
cosa maledetta romana per ora ho colpito
lo ri colpito bravo quando fa rumori in
acqua che lo colpisce si sente ma egli
esplosi in faccia sono schiacciati live
al muro no sto ancora via ex capi scappi
scappi lei
vado via non avrebbe spinge il muro se
non si ingloba il muro il muro ci spinge
quindi non si preoccupi sì sì sì sono
squadroni dossi sandrino localino locali
non ho armi
rimango qua sdraiato faccio finta di
morire vuole la katana o una granata e
basta è anche della dinamica le grazie
mi renda se vinciamo così mi mi guardi
nudo la faccio l'altro ancora questa
banana di merda e se non è possibile mi
ha scioccato
vengo da lei io gliele lancio le granate
a dismisura guardi guardi noi lanciato
un sacco
il closing grenade l'ho usata alla fine
oddio non buttate giù aspetti aspetti
erano posso si si si sta trascinando
aiuto la prendo non so se stiamo per
morire o cosa ma è stato bello giocare
con lei signor gatto sono contro tre
persone diciamo in tre rimasti ma ma lei
era catarra e contro 2
se riuscissi a lanciare la stan grenade
nel momento giusto sarebbe fattibile
no sono scemo no ma no mai se scendi si
muore ma va a cagare
porca vacca ci credevo perché non aveva
più armi neanche la banana non aveva
colpi sono rimasto molto contento
comunque
[Musica]
niente basta